let's take a look at this first story
which basically
uh contradicts everything the activists
have said
uh up until i guess this point from the
daily mail america's largest teachers
union backs teaching critical race
theory to children
says it will fight those who oppose the
move and calls for october rally
to commemorate george floyd's birthday
so this is it
we've heard over and over again that no
one's teaching critical race theory in
schools
it was a semantic game what they're
actually doing was they were they call
it praxis
theory and practice so they weren't
teaching you the writings of say
kimberly crenshaw
they were applying the ideology that she
had written about
into the teachings of these schools and
they're using derivative writings or
ideologies like anti-racism and critical
white studies
to indoctrinate your children now the
cat's out of the bag
the national educators association
announced it is backing the teaching of
critical race theory in schools
the country's largest teachers union
approved a resolution to promote
critical race theory
and assemble a team to teach it to union
members
it also wants to assemble a staffs take
on those who challenge its plans to
promote crt
in addition to its plans the nea will
launch a national day of action on
october 14th george floyd's birthday
to have a dialogue on systemic racism as
of june 29th
26 states have introduced bills or taken
steps to restrict teaching critical race
theory
it is unclear how the nea's plan to
teach crt
uh will be implemented in such states
i i gotta say i read some history
i am not optimistic we are we are we are
we are repeating
uh humans are repeating themselves in
this regard if you look back to the
1920s and what was going on in germany
i know it's extremely cliche to invoke
godwin's law and say oh they're just
like the nazis
they're not in the sense that they
believe the same things although
actually they kind of do uh racial
identitarianism
but you take a look at what happened in
the 20s
what happened with uh you know hitler
being this this uh
what do they call him the leader of the
reactionary extremists
and then eventually he won over the
country and the reason he did it
well and his own words is that he
indoctrinated children
right so that's what we're seeing so
here's here's where there's some
optimism though
steve bannon said on this show was a
week a week or so ago
yeah that we are going to win we're
going to defeat this this marxist
ideology the critical race theorists and
the establishment
just take a look at what's happening in
loudoun county with these parents who
are fighting back against critical race
theory
when these moms start seeing what's
being taught to their children
right they're gonna wake up and then he
liked it at the french revolution yeah
he said once the women
the wives came out that was it right
that
it was over they marched down to the
palace they took you know the king the
queen or whatever yeah
so maybe what we're seeing now with the
work you're doing azra and
and all these books you have to show us
is
it's it's calls for hope yeah i mean it
is cause for hope because
we got fed up we got fed up we just
decided
okay we've got our you know carpool that
we got to do we got to make dinner we
got to make a living
but we're not going to let garbage go
into our kids minds and
so that's what happened in my life and i
know that
every parent that i speak to is equally
motivated
there's you know nothing that will
stand between a parent and their child
because love is what connects us and
it's existential this is a being that
you brought into this world
you can lose a lot in this life you can
lose a job you can use a home but when
when your child is in threat of being
taken from you
in spirit and in mind there's nothing
that's going to stop you we saw this
viral story
last year where when i started doing
zoom courses
that the kids were now doing remote
teaching the there was a there was a
leaked video apparently some teacher was
like i'm really worried
what's going to happen if the parents
find out what we're teaching their kids
right
and then the parents found out what was
being taught to their kids yeah we
listen and you know what happens is
we're just shocked because all of a
sudden you
have entrusted the school system with
your kid's life
and now you see that in fact your
child's future
is threatened because they may end up in
this
very regressive mindset and that's
troubling and so
from new york city to beaverton oregon
you know we've got parents that are
standing up we've got teachers
what we've done at parents defending
education is created a little portal
and in that portal people report to us
their tips
and we put their tips we investigate
them i'm been a journalist 30 years
and i do the reporting and we all do the
reporting we've got
erica in rhode island we've got marisa
here in virginia
we've got nikki and virginia also and
parents all over the country
that are part of our movement and we're
putting them up on the map so that
everybody knows in every school district
what's going on
something crazy that's uh well well
i think people are familiar with the
higher profile battles that are
happening
the loudoun county being one of the the
biggest you have these parents that
they're in these videos they're going
viral yeah because effectively what's
happening is
these schools are teaching children that
they either are oppressed or oppressors
right because it basically marks this
theory
and a critical theory and they're saying
which is basically the same thing but i
digress
they're saying to these kids like
minorities you will never succeed
you can't succeed you're oppressed it'll
never happen yeah and there's no
solution offered up to that ideology
you tell someone you will always fail
have a nice day yeah
and so you're creating that bigotry of
low expectations for minorities and then
asians when we just say actually we like
math
you know and our kids are good at math
and
they go into the stem schools like my
son's school we're the inconvenient
minority right and then they want to
dismiss us
as white adjacent and that we're just
white now yeah
they they don't even bother they say
whiteness uh is
is this critical race theory that it's a
property that's that it's a tangible
thing
owned by people and that if you're
accepted then
basically asian people can be white now
here's the funny thing
our friend luke who is luke kowski
is on the show every so often he has
blonde hair and blue eyes
he is white but he's slavic so according
to the coalition
for communities of color they say that
he's a person of color as a slavic
individual blond-haired blue-eyed white
guy
yeah yeah because ultimately though the
identity
shouldn't be defined by these abstract
ideas and speaking of whiteness this is
one of those books that's actually sold
and taught to elementary school kids
called not my idea
the most startling page is this one now
this is this is in schools
this is in schools christopher ruffo
tweeted about this yeah this is this is
one of those books
it's uh taught in in pennsylvania
it's taught in texas and yeah what
is a bad deal it always was dude we can
see your pointy tail what does that mean
go to the next page it says contract
binding you to whiteness you'll get
stolen land stolen rich's special favors
whiteness gets quote uh check mark to
mess endlessly with the lives of your
friends neighbors
loved ones and all fellow humans of
color for the purpose of profit
your soul sign below land riches and
favors may be revoked at any time for
any reason
and the pointy tail is on a white man
is on the devil yeah the contract with
the devil
and that's what whiteness has and this
is going to third graders
can you imagine that a third grader has
to process nine-year-olds
yeah basically this kind of garbage it's
really toxicity
that's amazing i mean when i was a kid
we didn't learn these are complicated
concepts
yeah and if you want to talk about
colonization
and you want to talk about you know some
of these moments from history you don't
associate it then
with this every white child that exists
in
classrooms today it's really well it's
it's funny how
um there's none of it makes sense to be
completely honest i mean they say
asians are white adjacent then they say
asians are actually white
then they say stop asian hate right
right i don't
they gotta do their virtue signaling
right they gotta act like they care but
ultimately they don't care
because they're out to destroy asians uh
pursuit of merit merit exactly yes
what is it about asians that they get
lumped in with
whiteness and perhaps it's the
stereotype of the
stern asian parent telling their child
to work harder are you a doctor yet
you're not why not keep studying yeah
and that's that's the joke and
they don't like the idea that i suppose
that people pass down studiousness
i don't think it's racial right i think
it's cultural yeah and i think
what we're really talking about right
here is they call cultural marxism
but i think it's very communistic in the
sense that they don't want you to
believe you can succeed
because then what happens you're
dependent upon the government right
you're dependent upon some extern
external structure or system to provide
for you because you're oppressed you
can't do it right
in in in that book when they mention
that contract with whiteness yeah
do they offer up any positives of how to
succeed and how to overcome being
oppressed
well you have to get rid of your
whiteness you know first of all as a
human being
and then you have to say that racism is
what brought you down
right and you have to have this
acknowledgement of that and that is very
culty
yeah it is very culty and and this is
all the the books and literature of a
cult
and that's what i think is parallel in
what you were said about nazism i mean
i've heard you also talk about how
critical race theory you know isn't the
concept that we should put out there we
should just call it wokism right
well yeah i mean i mean whether it's
true or not like it's an ism
it's an ideology and that's what got me
into this because
as a journalist i'm always looking at
ideas and how they're sold
and how they're marketed out in the
world and that's what i then realized is
that there's this
multi-million dollar industry pushing
this ideology
and into our schools spineless
corporations to see a quick buck a
book a quick buck and in a book willing
to push it
yeah i say wokeness because critical
race theory is
has some specific ideas and there are
derivative ideas that don't
rest inside the writings of critical
race theorists
like and and they use these semantic
games to manipulate so perhaps
identitarianism
might might be a better way to describe
it and the reason i like saying
identitarianism it's it's
effectively the the the etymology is
identity plus
you know government form of government
yeah so you have government on the basis
of race
right granted it's very vague
considering everything they're talking
about because
it's deeper than just just government or
policy but they're very much so pushing
a way of life and policy based on your
race
very much so like the nazis did and so
if you want to find that
that common factor between the
authoritarian groups do they hold the
same economic views no of course not
and it becomes very silly when people
say oh so-and-so's a fascist it's like
the fascists had specific views on the
state and corporations
and the nazis had very specific views on
on race authoritarianism is the better
word but that's really broad
the thing that com that binds these with
the similar with what we've seen in the
in the past hundred years is
racial identitarianism combined with
authoritarianism i don't care
what kind of economic system you have if
you're an authoritarian in the first
place
and then outside of that race-based
authoritarianism is just
a million times freakier yeah and you
know i i
fit really well in the oppression matrix
because i'm
a muslim i'm a woman i
am an immigrant i lived in poverty when
my family moved to america
grew up in west virginia and so
i i could make out pretty well right in
this
suffering yes but the reason why i care
is because this ism that really
uh woke me up that was in my life
was islamism which is the
political islam so as a muslim i grew up
with
a very progressive interpretation of the
faith i didn't
grow up with thinking that i had to
cover my hair i brought as another
show and tell this doll who um looks
like a typical barbie
but when she arrived her name is fula
and she had her hair covered
she was wearing the black abaya that
women have to wear
right in saudi arabia and you'll see
that i
took her to vote with me one day i got
her the voting sticker because
uh you know women have been denied the
vote in these islamist countries
so there's being a muslim and then
there's believing in islam that
is about your identity and about
politics it has to be in governance and
so for the last
20 years after 9 11 i've been fighting
that
extremism and that's where i really
understood
this identity politics divides people
it's dangerous it kills people and
that's why
i know that the battle we're in is so
important and there's an interesting
point we made too with identity politics
there's
sort of a positive identity politics and
a negative identity politics and i think
it's hard to know exactly where the
dividing line is certainly we view the
civil rights act as a good thing
you can't discriminate on the basis of
race what we don't like is identity
politics where they say
you must discriminate on the basis of
race so that that's what i've run into
with some with many of these
left personalities they're like ah when
you say civil rights act you're playing
identity politics and i'm like i'm
saying you can't
use someone's you know race to
discriminate and then they say
you can but it's really fascinating
though we they they then say
you can't discriminate on the basis of
sex they they say
it's it's a really confusing thing to
become really honest but maybe we'll get
it in a second
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time